[Music]
[Music]
oh man that's beautiful
muttering oh that's so Tim we're all
gonna be spending a lot more time at
home it's fair to say over the coming
weeks and months is now the time to get
back to proper home cooking it's
important to have a few basic things
that might be useful I thought today we
start off by doing a really simple loaf
of bread have you got your here I've
gotten a mixing bowl yeast
real yeast right proper this is fresh
all I've got is dried yeast but they're
they're roughly the same thing so your
bowl on your scale yeah and then just
way into that 500 grams of flour I've
often heard people say baking is a
science you have to really be precise
yeah oh yes absolutely
it's all that stovetop nonsense whose
flame and fire that's easy this stuff is
this stuff is serious science I'm using
strong bread flour I had two hands high
and low for this strong bread flour it's
not everywhere at the moment people have
empty the shelves in a lot of places if
I had another type of flour can I could
I do something similar or does it have
to be they can do this with general
purpose regular flour not self-raising
but regular flour you can do it you
probably won't get as nice a crust there
is nicer crumb but you'll be able to get
all perfectly working serviceable loaf I
want to measure seven grams of the yeast
it might get 50 grams even he knows I'm
using the fresh yeast on to one side of
the flour now when we're on pouring mine
you crumble yours up to the other side
horan 10 grams of salt and weigh 350
grams of a tepid water right into the
middle of that flower now you are going
to get really flowery and messy
you're gonna use your fingers mix it and
blend it this is where it gets
therapeutic there this is still feeling
quite wet and my fingers okay this this
does say web don't worry about that now
here's a very weird question do you
travel much with work well not at the
moment but in the past oh yeah you see
are you one of those people that makes
the shower caps I think I've ever done
that
see I'm the only bald man in the world
who makes the shower caps but the shower
caps in hotels are really really good
for covering dough then you can see
inside how did those rising but it's
don't worry about that
I've just admitted that at least my
stockpiles or something relatively
benign cover it up with a boost down
cloth over the next hour or so to come
down and check it and see if it's sort
of starting to move and puff up just
having a look at this thing it looks
kind of gelatinous should I be worried
about that no that's really really good
you know when people think about bread
usually they think about kneading it a
lot this gelatinous quality means that
the bruton's gluten is breaking down
without having to be beaten up what you
need to do there is get your hands wet
turn it and kind of fold it on itself a
few times stretching the dough and
lifting it into the middle of making a
little tight ball and then put the cover
back on and leave it for a couple more
hours and more time as you stretch and
fold but stronger the gluten becomes and
therefore when it puffs up it's really
going to go like a rocket think about it
as a sort of a day-long process how is
your day looking it's looking pretty
thorough don't shake it oh shake it
don't shake it
no no just that's looking pretty good
looking good that's good stop job we're
not about but the air out just being a
little bit too enthusiastic there be
gentle
gentlemen there watch okay here we go
take the lid off and check it my lord
that looks beautiful
yes you need to put crypts of enclosed
environment in which you can't cook hot
and hard and quickly so we're going to
do it inside one of these pots why why
one of these pots and not kind of a more
conventional bread tin bread tin would
work you could easily put it into a red
tint but it won't be so pretty put a
squirt of oil into it we're going to put
a little bit of flour on the table in
front of us pour the dough add the kind
of crusty top of the dough goes down
onto the flour and the wet underside
stays upright reached onto the far side
you put your fingers underneath the done
try enough lift it and fold in like
little rabbit ears then you turn it
around and put in rabbit ears on the
next to the other two corners so you're
pulling these thin things into the
center and if it sticks a bit put a bit
more flour dough do you see how it's
sort of tightening up into a ball once
you've got it reasonably tight and it's
kind of holding together chuck up a
flower on it flip it over so the neat
side is upwards watch this movement you
kind of get your fingers under it and
turning it you're tightening it you you
cannot probably already see in the
surface of it
that there's little bubbles forming and
stuff happening underneath but that's
stretchy skin you're making its what's
going to hold the bugger together
finally put your hands right underneath
it pick it up like that move it over the
top of your liquor is a and gently drop
it inside just like putting a baby in
the bath and now let's all push it out a
little bit no no let's let it do that by
itself and let it expand against the
outside to see what I mean and when it's
doubled we slash it and put it in a hot
oven the bread has risen beautifully
yours looks great it looks better than
mine actually really why it's still
quite flat yeah but I think I've used
the bigger pan than yours so why it's
probably too larger one cut a big slash
in the top so the bread opens up and the
cross comes up through it I'm a bit
nervous then it's kind of stretching and
deflating the dough somewhat just fine
don't worry take your glass of water
open the oven door put this inside RIE
the center and then throw the half glass
of water into the oven not into the pot
steam transmits the heat a lot faster
than just dry air also the steam
gelatinizes the outside it gives it that
lovely sort of rubbery finish which then
crisps off as it bakes okay it's the
moment the truth
and it smells fantastic oh man that's
beautiful yeah as I look that is
staggeringly good
okay so shake it a bit is it loose in
the pot yeah just basically turn turn
your low power on to it biggest one how
it goes oh that's making a satisfying
noise put a caption like Ron one would
have been good in a smaller the same so
we're gonna inspire that's not good
there's a good distribution in there so
a little air bubbles go through what's
written pretty good soup unsalted butter
using salty of course has to be they
also find it incredibly rewarding as
well as delicious oh not a butter on
them at all and that's with it
[Music]